in the last video i promised you that i
would show a concrete example of
electrophilic aromatic substitution so
let's do that right here so let's say we
have some benzene
we've got some
benzene
we've got some benzene it's the solution
with some molecular bromine so i'll draw
the molecular bromine like this
so it's one bromine right there it has
one two three four five six seven
valence electrons and it's bonded to
another bromine
that has one two three four five six
seven electrons and these two guys in
the middle are bonded to each other they
can kind of act as an electron pair or
make both bromines feel like they have
eight electrons this guy thinks he has a
magenta one that guy thinks he has the
blue one and let's say we have some
iron bromide in our mix as well and
we're going to see is that this is going
to catalyze the reaction so the iron
bromide
we have some iron and it's bonded to
three bromines
it's bonded to three bromines
just like that so we haven't seen iron
bromide much but the way i think about
it is that the bromine molecules are
much more electronegative than the iron
so even though these look like fair
covalent bonds if you thought about
oxidation these guys are going to be
hogging the electrons this actually
would have an oxidation number of three
and in reality they are hogging the
electrons they are more electronegative
so the way i think about it is that this
iron
will have a slightly positive charge
because the electrons are being hogged
away from it from it so it wouldn't mind
to gain an electron or it might want to
accept an electron it might want to act
as a lewis acid remember lewis acid will
accept an electron
so this might want to act as a
lewis
as a lewis acid so who can it nab
electrons from well maybe you can nab an
electron from this bromine right here
and you know i'm not saying that this is
always going to occur but under the
right circumstances if they bump into
each other with the right energies it
can happen
so this electron let me do it in a
different color that i haven't used yet
this green color let's say this electron
right here gets nabbed by
that iron then what do we have well then
we have a situation we have this bromine
the blue one with one two three four
five six seven valence electrons we have
the magenta bromine with
with one two three four five now it only
has the sixth valence electron right
here the seventh got nabbed by the iron
so the iron has the seventh valence
electron and then you have the rest of
the molecule
so then you have your iron
you have your iron and it's attached of
course to the three bromines
to the
three
to the three bromines just like that and
then our bonds these guys were bonded
they still are bonded and now these guys
are bonded these were in a pair this
electron jumped over to the iron now we
have another bond but because this
bromine lost an electron it was neutral
it lost an electron it now has a
positive charge
it now has a positive charge and the
iron now that it gained this electron
now has a negative charge
it
so let's think about what's going to
happen now now we're going to get the
we're going to bring the benzene into
the mix so let me redraw the benzene let
me redraw
the benzene
just like
that and we have this double bond
that double bond and then just to make
things clear let me draw this double
bond with the two electrons on either
end so you have the orange electron
you have your green electron right over
there and i'll draw the double bond as
being green
now let's think about this molecule
right here we have a bromine with a
positive charge bromines are really
really really electronegative you might
see them with a negative charge with a
positive charge it really wants to grab
an electron and in the right
circumstances you can imagine where it
really wants to grab it really really
really really wants to grab that
electron right there so maybe if there's
just some way it could pull this
electron but the only way it could pull
this electron is maybe if this because
if it just took that electron then this
bromine would have a positive charge
which isn't cool so this bromine maybe
would want to pull an electron if this
guy gets an electron then this guy can
get an electron so you can imagine this
thing this thing as a whole
really really wants to grab an electron
it might be very good at doing it so
this is our strong electrophile so what
actually will happen in the bromination
of this benzene ring and let me draw
some hydrogens here just to make just to
make things clear we already have we
already have hydrogens on all of these
carbons it's sometimes important to
visualize this when we're doing
electrophilic aromatic substitutions
so we already have a hydrogen on all of
these molecules so maybe this is so
electrophilic it can actually break the
aromatic ring nab this electron right
there so maybe this electron right there
this electron right there goes to the
bromine
goes to there maybe i should even do it
this way just so you make it clear it
kind of replaces that one although you
know obviously the electrons are a bit
fungible so maybe it goes
over there and then when it goes to this
let me make it clear it's going to the
blue bromine so this electron right here
goes to the blue
bromine if that if the blue bromine gets
an electron then it can let go of this
blue electron so this blue electron can
then go to this bromine right over here
and then what does our situation look
like well if we have that then let me
draw our benzene ring first
we have our benzene ring first
so let me draw the benzene ring
benzene ring this double bond that
double bond let me draw all of the
hydrogens
one hydrogen i want to do them in purple
i want to do them in purple so we have
one hydrogen two hydrogens
three hydrogens four hydrogens five
hydrogens and six hydrogens this orange
electron is still with this carbon right
here so this orange electron is still
with this carbon right here but that
electron got nabbed by this bromine
so that electron
got nabbed by
this bromine right over here
by that bromine i've kind of flipped it
around and now it has its other six
valence electrons one two three four
five six the electron got taken away
from this carbon so now that carbon will
have a positive charge but we saw in the
last video it's actually resonant
stabilized that electron could jump
there that electron can jump there so
it's not as stable as a nice nice
aromatic benzene ring like this but it's
not a ridiculous carbocation it's stable
enough for it to exist for some small
amount of time while we kind of hit our
transition state and then this molecule
over here what's it going to look like
what's it going to look like well this
bromine had a positive charge it had a
positive charge now it gained an
electron let me draw it
so you have
you have your bromine
you have your bromine it
gained an electron so now it is neutral
again so let's see it had the one one
two three four five
six now it gained this blue electron so
now it's seven valence electrons back to
being neutral it's bonded to the iron
bromide
bonded to the iron bromide
we draw the bromines one
two
three
and so we've given this for this blue
bromine to the benzene ring but it's not
happy here it doesn't want to
break its aromaticity it wants an
electron back so how can it gain an
electron back well this thing actually
let me make it very clear let me make it
clear this thing had a negative charge
this thing had a negative charge right
here so you can imagine saying this we
had this electron right here
so maybe this thing right over here can
now act as an actual base it can nab a
proton off of the benzene ring just like
we saw in the last video this is now the
base this whole complex to some degree
acted as a strong electrophile now that
we got one rid of one of these bromines
this thing might want to grab a proton
now since it is positive and will act as
our base and we'll nab one of these
protons if it nabs the proton then the
leftover electron is still there that
electron is still there let me do that
in a different color
that electron is still doing in red that
electron is still there and then that
electron can be given to that original
carbo cation and will have a nice
aromatic ring again so how would that
look so you could imagine
you could imagine a situation
where this electron this green electron
right here
gets given
given to the hydrogen nucleus if it's
given to that hydrogen nucleus then this
red electron right here can then be
given to the carbocation and then what
are we left with
what are we left with
well we have our we draw
what we started with
so we have our ring we have this double
bond and that double bond right there
now let me draw all of our hydrogens we
have this hydrogen
that hydrogen
this one over here
this one over here and we have this one
over here now this hydrogen just now got
nabbed so this hydrogen over here got
nabbed it got given actually the
hydrogen nucleus got given this green
electron it got given this green
electron which is paired with this
magenta one right over here so it's
paired with this magenta one right over
here so it is now bonded to the bromine
we now have hydrogen bromide and this
had one two three four five
six other valence electrons i'll keep
i'll keep the colors consistent and
this is now bonded now this electron
went away from the iron so the iron will
now lose its negative charge the iron
bromide so now it is back in its
original form it is now back in its
original form so we have our iron
bonded to three bromines
we are bonded to three bromines
just like that it has lost its negative
charge and
this
this electron right here has now gone to
the carbocation
so that electron right there has now
gone to the carbocation it is right
there so this bond you can imagine is
now
part you can imagine it now being this
double bond
so it was magenta so i'll draw it in
magenta just there and we can't forget
the whole point of this whole video was
the bromination so now we now have this
bromo group there
so we have this orange electron is right
over here and it is bonded to
it is bonded to
that bromine
it is bonded to that bromine
just like that and we have brominated
the benzene ring using and just let's be
clear we had a negative charge and a
positive charge now it's cancelled out
the thing with the negative charge gave
an electron to the positive charge it is
now neutral that is now neutral now
let's be clear on what happened here we
want to just to map it to what we saw
before we had a benzene ring
right here we have no strong
electrophile or strong base yet it had
to become a strong electrophile when
this thing gave an electron to the iron
bromine and became this larger molecule
now this whole thing can act as a pretty
strong electrophile this grabbed an
electron it broke
it broke the aromaticity of the benzene
ring but just long enough
long enough for this bromine to form but
once this bromine it it gained an
electron and then and bonded to the
benzene gave and then gave up an
electron to this other bromine that
really wanted to get an electron because
it had a positive charge and then once
it got it now this whole thing acted as
the base so we kind of have the same
molecule changing up a little bit acting
as an electrophile or acting as a base
and then once it acts as a base
this bromine this magenta bromine nabs
the proton allows this electron to go
back to that carbocation and then we're
left with the iron broma bromide again
so this thing really didn't change
through the whole reaction that's why we
can call it a catalyst it wasn't one of
the reagents one of the reactants in the
reaction hopefully you found that
vaguely interesting